patience impatience they patient
Haitians be patient patience patience
patience
hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about how you can be patient and
as always if you hear something that
really really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well enjoy patience is for
the impatient that in fact when you're
getting started in your in-laws are
making faces at you and you're not sure
if you're going to be able to pay the
rent and you don't know why you're
living in Brooklyn to begin with and
you're going to have to move back to
Florida it's easy to say you know what I
need to go faster to pick up these
scraps to pick up these scraps and
sometimes what that does is it gives you
the foot up to get to the next level but
sometimes what that does is it just
makes your scrap collector and that one
of the things that we see when we look
at the work of people who have put
really big ideas into the world who have
built online platforms right is that
they got there by being patiently
impatient or impatiently patient
whichever way you want to juxtapose it
that if you look around at the blog's
you read or that the people you respect
online or the organization's you want to
work with the myth of the overnight
success is just that a myth that you
know the much-vaunted Twitter was a
failure a complete failure for two years
nobody used it and if they took the
mindset of well if it doesn't work in
two weeks we got to go do something else
you never would have heard of it you
know we I come from a people very
passionate hobby in what a what I need
right away everyone
sometimes it's sometimes and in the Red
Room is the quickest way to get there
sometimes you got to take a little long
to achieve the things you wanna achieve
in life so don't be in a hurry be
patient be patient everybody wants
everything in our universe society
that's instant gratification Instagram
is it is be patient it was kind of tough
knowing that sometimes I work so hard
and everybody else and I wasn't saying I
wasn't reaping the benefits of it and I
wasn't I wasn't getting any better as
quickly as I wanted to but I stayed
patient and that was one big thing for
me is knowing when to stay patient that
everything is gonna come around and I
think that uh you know with that
patience I gained as a kid it's helping
me in the NBA right now so you know for
me is just you know always always
working hard and always trying to get
better and knowing I can get better
knowing it you know I didn't get to and
I'm not there where I want to be yet so
I have a long ways to go so a bunch of
group of really brilliant psychologists
in the field of expertise research I
have sat down and tried to figure out
how long do you have to work at
something before you become really good
right and the answer seems to be is an
extraordinary consistent answer in an
incredible number of fields and that is
you need to have practice to have
apprenticed for 10,000 hours before you
get good so every great classical
composer without exception composes for
at least 10 years before they write
their masterwork Mozart
10:30 is composing at 11:00 but he's
composing garbage at 11:00 I mean he
doesn't produce something great until
he's 22 or 23 concerto number nine I
think 271 if I asked you how long did it
take you when you were doing this job
before you felt comfortable and good at
what you were doing 10 years old in use
yeah I was same with me all right
Vincent gotta be consistent finding in
it it's really important because it says
that we are far too impatient with
people when we when we when we assess
whether someone has
got what it takes to do a certain job we
always want to make that assessment
after six months or a year or and that's
ridiculous
you know the kinds of jobs we have
people do today are sufficiently complex
that they require a long time to reach
mastery and what we should be doing is
setting up institutions and structures
that allow people to spend the time and
effort to reach mastery not judging them
prematurely I talked to so many smart
fantastic ambitious idealistic
hard-working kids and they're right out
of college they're they're entry-level
jobs and I'll ask them how is it going
and they'll say I think I'm gonna quit
and I'm like why they say to me I'm not
making an impact I'm like you know
you've been here eight months right they
treat the sense of fulfillment or even
love like it's a scavenger hunt like
it's something you look for my
millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired I mean it was mutual or they're
quitting because they're not making an
impact or they're not find anything
they're looking for they're not feeling
fulfilled as if it's a scavenger hunt
love a job you find joy from is not
something you discover it's not like I
found love here it is I found a job I
love that's not how it works
both of those things require hard work
you are in love because you work very
hard every single day of your life to
stay in love you find a job that brings
you ultimate joy because you work hard
every single day to serve those around
you and you maintain that joy it's not a
discovery but the problem is the sense
of impatience it's as if an entire
generation is standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want they can see the summit what they
can't see is the mountain this large
emove Abul object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about take a helicopter climb I
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys the problem is this entire
generation has an institutionalized
sense of impatient
and do they have the patience to go on
the journey to maintain love to feel
fulfilled or do they just quit and on to
the next dump and on to the next ghost
and on to the next I've learned over the
years that you know with anything you
have to be patient not in five years
patient or five you know five months
patient you know you could be ten years
patient if you want you know
empires aren't built overnight you know
I mean like I always tell you by the
great wall was a 2000 year old plan
mm you're made lifetimes that is a one
plan you know and getting people to to
to kind of you know do the same have the
same exact agenda for lifetimes the
generations what's crazy so you have to
be patient when you want to do something
significant no matter what and a lot of
time that means you know not reaping the
benefits of something immediately
and that's the chest dedicate a certain
amount of time to the business two hours
a week four hours a week 50 hours a week
no matter what it starts to compound
after the year one after year two after
your three if you dedicated two hours a
week to you know this new hobby or love
or you know business you know at the end
of the year it's over a hundred hours
put in don't be in a rush first we'll
learn all the mistakes early and then
have some kind of strategy know that
this is where you want to be after year
one two three four and five and you have
to really be honest with yourself is the
business worth it is it costing too much
because you'll know so you know Charlie
Munger likes to say that you don't make
money when you buy stocks and you don't
make money when you sell stocks you make
money by waiting and so the biggest the
single biggest advantage a value
investor has is not IQ it's patience and
waiting waiting for the right pitch and
waiting for many years for the right
pitch there's a there's a phrase in the
Bible that's become kind of an
expression called suffer fools gladly
and somehow in our modern world the cup
totally inverted which is something that
it kind of bothers me the original
expression meant that you're constantly
surrounded by fools half the world are
fools or whatever the percentage is and
and maybe you're a bit of a fool and
what you need to do is you need to suck
you need to be able to put up with fools
and laugh at them and not take them
seriously that's what it means in the
Bible and that's the wisdom in the Bible
and then somehow it got turned around in
modern times where where it seems to be
a virtue that you don't suffer fools
gladly that you don't put up with them
that you get angry about them that you
confront them that you try to change
them and on and on and on and on and on
and the idea that I try to say
part of my chapter on social
intelligence which is I try and tell you
that you're not going to be a master in
this world unless you know how to get
along with people we're social animals
you can't just be a nerd a tech guy has
no contact with people you have to learn
how to be with people and be socially
intelligent and it's actually a
beautiful form of intelligence and one
of the aspects is to learn how to suffer
fools gladly and I tell you what I think
a fool is a fool is somebody that
doesn't have the right kind of sense of
priorities in life they magnify the
little things that we should just not
worry about into some huge dramatic
thing and huge dramatic things that
completely ignore they have no sense of
proportion and we encounter them every
day in our lives and in fact we
encounter a little bit of them in
ourselves we all have a foolish side so
let's all be patient with fools if you
try and change them or fight them you're
only going to waste valuable time and
energy in your short life learn to laugh
at them learn to know it's part of the
human comedy I find that that's going to
save you energy in the end and I have
stories in there of how not only do you
suffer fools gladly but you turn it
around to an advantage so I have a story
in there Daniel
Everett who's a great kind of
anthropologist and linguist and he came
out with a radical new theory on
linguistics and suddenly he finds
himself being attacked by everyone in
the field but they're attacking him in
this ad hominem manner as if he's a
charlatan they're not attacking his
ideas and it's driving him crazy and now
he's dealing with fools and he decides
that what he's going to do is he's going
to turn it to his advantage he's going
to make sure now from now on that
anything he presents in a book or a
lecture is airtight they would usually
pinpoint one little small thing and
something he said that could be
inconsistent and say therefore your
whole theory is wrong okay from now on
I'm not going to be anything
inconsistent so he took the foolish
aspect of these attacks and he decided
he would make it would make him stronger
and it would make his ideas stronger
that's what suffer fools gladly is about
and I have other examples there in the
book there's not going to happen as
quickly as you want it to happen a lot
of things going to happen that will
catch you off guard and so therefore
you've got to deal with and handle it as
it comes and not only that but that
faith and patience drives you into
action you've got to keep moving and
keep plugging away and the Far East I
have something that's called the Chinese
bamboo tree the Chinese bamboo tree
takes five years to grow and when they
go through a process of growing it they
have to water and fertilize the ground
where it is every day and it doesn't
break through the ground until the fifth
year okay but once it breaks through the
ground within five weeks
it grows 90 feet tall now the question
is does it grow 90 feet tall in five
weeks or five years the answer is
obvious it grows 90 feet tall in five
years because at any time had that
person stopped watering and nurturing
and fertilizing that dream that bamboo
tree would have died in the ground I can
see people coming out talking to a guy
out there watering and fertilizing the
ground that's not showing anything hey
what you doing
keep it out here a long time man
and the conversation in the neighborhood
is you've drawn a Chinese bamboo tree
that right yeah that's right well uh
even Ray Charles and Stevie Wonder can
see ain't none show
give us are people gonna do you how long
you been working on this how long have
you been working on your dream it's good
and you have nothing to show this is all
you got to show people gonna do that to
you and some people ladies and gentlemen
they stopped because they don't see
instant results it doesn't happen
quickly they stop oh no no no you got to
keep on watering your dream and when it
began to happen they stopped laughing
they said look whoa look at it look up
hey man you know I know you can do it
looking good you got a job here thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what did you
think did you like the video what did
you pull from it what would your
favorite thought are you patient enough
in your business leave all that in the
comments below let me know what you
think I'm gonna join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon